Сара бореться за свою віру.
За віру в її розумінні.
Сара представляє жінок, які носять нікаб в Данії.
Батьки Сари - мігранти з Туреччини, дівчина народилася і виросла в Данії.
Кілька років тому вона вирішила приховати своє обличчя з релігійних міркувань,
але з 1 серпня їй заборонено робити це в громадських місцях.
Сара вбачає в цьому порушення її прав.
Я дуже розчарована. Я думала, що ми живемо у вільному суспільстві,
де люди можуть вірити в те, у що вони хочуть вірити
і одягатися так, як вони хочуть, якщо це нікому не заважає.
Тепер вона і її соратниці роздають листівки проти заборони носіння нікаба.
Іноді Сара чує слова підтримки.
Чоловіки знову вказують жінкам, як вони повинні одягатися.
Це смішно і не допоможе нікому.
Цією забороною ми швидше відштовхуємо цих людей від суспільства.
Ми повинні визнати, що існують культурні відмінності.
Зустріч у парламенті Данії. Сара має намір поспілкуватися з ініціатором нового закону.
Мадс Фугледе з правлячої ліберальної партії "Венстре" переконаний,
що носіння такого одягу в публічних місцях необхідно заборонити.
Навіть з огляду на те, що в Данії, всього близько двох сотень жінок носять нікаб або паранджу.
Ви нічого не знаєте про іслам!
А ви ставите закони шаріату вище, ніж нашої правової системи.
Адже саме це ви і хочете дати мені зрозуміти.
Саме тому нам потрібні закони проти тих цінностей, які ви захищаєте.
Мені шкода, але це так.
Ні, ми живемо в Данії, і тут - свобода віросповідання.
Непроста розмова.
Нікаб - це символ релігійної свободи чи символ поневолення жінки?
Кожен залишився при своїй думці.
Нікаб, хіджаб та інший подібний одяг, що закриває обличчя і частини тіла -
це інструменти, мета яких - контролювати і пригнічувати жінок.
Ми будемо боротися з цим.
А що думають про це чоловіки-мусульмани?
Ми в мечеті імама Алі.
Всі, з ким поспілкувалася знімальна група DW, вважають цю заборону правильною.
Я проти приховування обличчя.
Хустка на голові - окей, як і довгий одяг.
Але я абсолютно проти того, щоб жінки закривали своє обличчя.
Ми - мусульмани, які живуть у західній країні.
І ми повинні пристосуватися до життя тут. Настільки, наскільки дозволяє іслам.
Якщо ви хочете бути частиною демократичного суспільства,
то з нікабом матимете багато незручностей.
Якщо ви хочете жити в ізоляції - то будь ласка.
Серед противників нікаба - і місцевий імам.
Іслам нікому не наказує закривати обличчя.
Але якщо жінка сама хоче цього, вона може це робити.
Моя точка зору збігається з тим, що говорить іслам:
жінки повинні носити відповідний одяг, який покриває тіло і волосся.
Сара усвідомлює, що якщо вона і далі хоче носити нікаб у громадських місцях,
то не зможе виходити з власної квартири.
Інакше їй загрожує штраф у розмірі 135 євро.
А починаючи з четвертого порушення, ця сума зросте аж до 1350 євро.